اراضي المانيا ستصبح اهدافا
مشروعة لنا وخطتهم محكوم عليها
بالفشل. نعم لقد فجرتها موسكو
بهذا الاعلان. وواشنطن ترد بسلاح
قد يغير مجرى الحرب الاوكرانية
وبوتين يختبر سلاحا بقدرات نووية
يدخل خط الحرب ضد الاوكران.
بريطانيا تساعد الطباخ بوتين سرا
من تحت الطاولة. بينما الصين
تخترق بريطاني لتكشف اسرارا من
العيار الثقيل واغلاق غامض
لعاصمة كيم جونج اون والجارة
الجنوبية تحذر. والبحر المتوسط
يشهد اعنف مناورة عسكرية بين
الامريكان واسرائيل والعرب
يقاطعون المنتجات السويدية
والاقتصاد السويدي يخر سريعا.
الغرب وموسكو الى ساحة الحرب.
وكثرت الطلبات والاستغاثات
والمدن الاوكرانية تسقط. هيا
ايها الحلفاء لا تتركون يقولها
الاوكرانيون. فهل من يلبي
النداء؟ وبعد كل ذلك الالحاح
يبدو ان اسارير الزيلينسكي
وحكومته ستبتسم قليلا وسينكشف
ضيقه. برلين وواشنطن تلبيان نداء
الاوكران. وها هو المستشار
الالماني اولفشولدز يوافق على
تزويد اوكرانيا بدباب القتالية
بل ان شولدز وافق على اعادة
تصديرها من الدول الشريكة ايضا
الى كياب. وذلك بحسب وكالة
الانباء الالمانية لتعلن الحكومة
الالمانية انها تهدف لتأسيس
كتيبتي دبابات ليوبارتو من اجل
اوكرانيا تتضمن اربع عشرة دبابة
بحسب رويترز. لكن هل كل تلك
الجلبة من اجل اربع عشرة دبابة
فقط يا احفاد هتلر المجموعة قد
يدمرها بوتين فور دخولها من حدود
اوكرانيا. رد الروس جاء على لسان
متحدث انديمتري بسكوف الذي قال
ان تسليم كييف دبابات نيوفارد
سيترك اثرا لا يمحى على العلاقات
مع برلين. ولن يأتي بخير على
علاقات المانيا وروسيا مستقبلا
لكن ما لن ماذا عن الجانب
الامريكي في الولايات المتحدة
يتحدثون عن سلاح جديد سيحل ضيفا
ثقيلا على حرب روسيا واوكراندا.
امريكا بصدد ارسال دبابات
ايفرانز بعد جدل كبير وقد شاركت
هذه الدبابات في حروب الخليج
وافغانستان والعراق. وهي مقاومة
للمواد المتفجرة وللرد على تزويد
الغرب كييه بالدبابات واسلحة
نوعية ها هي موسكو تجهز صواريخ
الزركون ذات القدرات النووية
لدخول المعارك. حيث اختبرت
الروسية اطلاق صواريخ زركون من
الفرقاطة ادمينال جورشكوف بمدى
يصل لتسعمائة كيلومتر. وقالت
الوزارة الروسية انها اجرت
تدريبات على صواريخ تفوق سرعتها
سرعة الصوت. ليستمر الرد الروسي.
وهنا يعود بسكوف ليقول ان الخطة
الغربية محكوم عليها بالفشل لان
ذلك مبالغة في تقدير الامكانات
التي ستضيفها للجيش الاوكراني.
مؤكدا ان هذه الدبابات ستحترق
مثل غيرها وهي باهظة الثمن فحسب
وفق قوله. اما في التلفزيون
الروسي الحكومي. فقالوا ان ظهور
الدبابات الالمانية في اوكرانيا
سيقودوا موسكو الى اعتبار
الاراضي الالمانية والقواعد
العسكرية والمواقع الاخرى اهدافا
مشروعة. ليقولها ميدفيديف صريحة
في وجههم دعوا صانعي بايدن وشولز
يوقفان دقات الساعة الذرية لفترة
من الوقت للقيام بذلك عليهما ان
يفهما ان سهمهما الاوكراني صدأ
منذ فترة طويلة. وذلك وفق وسائل
اعلام روسي. وبعد معارك صعبة ها
هو الجيش الاوكراني يعلن انسحابه
من بلدة سوليدر شرق البلاد بينما
كانت روسيا قد اعلنت سيطرتها على
البلدة قبل هناك انتقلت الحرب من
سوليدر لتتحول الى حرب شوارع
داخل احياء وشوارع مدينة بخمود.
هنا جاء دور الامم المتحدة
لتتدخل باعلانها ان اول قافلة
مساعدات انسانية اممية وصلت الى
محيط بلدة سوليدار شرق اوكرانيا
التي شهدت اشرس المعارك منذ
بداية الحرب. من جانبه الجيش
الاوكراني يجري تدريبات عسكرية
منطقة والمتحدث باسم الاستخبارات
الاوكرانية يقول ان روسيا عدلت
في قيادتها العسكرية وانهت
المرحلة الاولى من التعبئة وبدأت
التقدم نحو اوكرانيا استعدادا
لهجوم قوي. لننتقل الى حمى
التغيير وبعد تصاعد حملة
الاقالات والاستقالات في
اوكرانيا على خلفية نشر تقارير
اعلامية عن تهم فساد تتعلق بشراء
امدادات باسعار مضاعفة. المتحدثة
باسم الخارجية الروسية ماريا
زاخاروفا ان ذلك عبارة عن اعادة
تقسيم نفوذ. من اوكرانيا الى
بريطانيا. تستمر هجمات الدب
الروسي لتزعم منصة الاستقصائية
ان الحكومة البريطانية ساعدت
مؤسس مجموعة فاجنر الروسية
الملقب بطباخ بوتين في التحايل
على عقوب فرضتها لندن لتتمكن
المجموعة من شن حملة على عمليات
اختراق لاكثر من خمسين شركة
ووكالة حكومية بريطانية وذلك في
اعقاب العملية العسكرية الروسية
لاوكرانيا وفق ما ذكرته صحيفة
التايمز البريطانية. وقالت
المنصة انها لا تعرف هوية
القراصنة الالكترونيين لكن ليس
لديها ما يدعوها للشك في صحة
المعلومات. الصين تخترق الجدران
الاوروبية. ليس كل ما يلمع ذهب.
ولا كل الاجهزة الالكترونية امنة
بعد اليوم في بريطانيا ولندن
تخشى كل ما يمكن للصينيين التدخل
فيه. لكن الصين تدخل في صناعة كل
شيء يا هؤلاء فالى اين المفر.
هنا وزراء بريطانيون يحذرون من
ان الصين لديها القدرة على على
ملايين الاشخاص في بريطانيا من
خلال سلاح الرقائق الالكترونية
المدمجة في السيارات والاجهزة
المنزلية وحتى المصابيح
الكهربائية. بل ومعظم الاجهزة
الالكترونية لتصف الرقائق
الالكترونية بفخ حصان طروادة
الذي يستخدمه اصحاب العيون
الضيقة. حتى انه يمكن لبكين ايضا
مراقبة تحركات الاهداف عبر محطات
الدفع بالبطاقة المصرفية. وكذا
كمعرفة من كانوا يقابلون ومتى
وفقا لتقرير نشرته صحيفة تليجراف
البريطانية. الزعيم الكوري وحرب
الظلام. هدأت عاصفة صواريخه
قليلا وتوارى عن الاعلام لبعض
الوقت. لكن هل تستطيع وسائل
الاعلام ان تعمل دون ذكر زعيم
كوريا الشمالية كيم جونغ اون وهي
كوريا الجنوبية تقول ان هناك
حكوميا ورد لدى جارتها الشمالية
جاء فيه ان كوريا الشمالية قررت
اغلاق العاصمة بيونج يانج لمدة
خمسة ايام بحسب ان كي نيوز
الكورية الجنوبية. وذكر الموقع
الذي يرصد اخبار كوريا الشمالية
ان الاخطار لم يشر الى فيروس
كورونا لكنه اوضح ان السكان في
المدينة عليهم البقاء في منازلهم
حتى نهاية يوم الاحد ويجب ان
يخضعوا لقياس درجة الحرارة من
مرة في اليوم الواحد. حتى ان
السكان في العاصمة بدأوا يخزنون
السلعة على ما يبدو تحسبا
لاجراءات اكثر صرامة بحسب وكالة
روتز. وفي الوقت الذي لم تؤكد
فيه التقارير نوع المرض التنفسي
الذي تحدثت عنه السلطات الكورية
الا ان بعض التقارير تشير الى
تفش جديد لفيروس كورونا. رغم ان
الرئيس الكوري الشمالي كيم جونغ
اون اعلن الانتصار على هذا في
بلاده. فما الذي يخطط له
المجنون? ولما كل هذا الغموض?
الاحداث والتطورات. انطلاق
مناورات عسكرية ضخمة بين امريكا
واسرائيل في البحر المتوسط تحاكي
ضرب ايران. ملايين من الناشطين
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
يطلقون حملة لمقاطعة المنتجات
السويدية ردا على حرق نسخة من
المصحف الشريف ليشهد السويدي اول
عاصفة تهز كيانه ويبدأ بعد
خسائره. هنا الاردن وبرغم تعهد
نتنياهو في عمان بن خفير يتحدى
الاردن ويؤكد مواصلته اقتحام
الاقصى. كشف وزير الخارجية
الامريكي السابق مايك بومبيو ان
الهند وباكستان اقتربتا من حرب
نووية في العام الفين وتسعة عشر
وان الولايات المتحدة تدخلت
لتمنع التصعيد ذلك الوقت. دبابات
الغرب ستغير واقع الحرب
الاوكرانية بحسب ما وعد بها
الاوكران. بينما الروس توعدوا
بحرقها قبل وصولها. فمن سيصل
لغايته ومن